で瞑想するんだから 特に仏教の初期仏教の場合はサマーディ瞑想というヨーガ的な瞑想をまず先にやって
それから心の訓練はしっかり身について
煩悩をいくらか抑えてもらって
智慧が鋭くしてからこのヴィパッサナーに入っちゃうっていうことをずっとその統率でしたから
で ヴィパッサナー瞑想するときは
このわざわざサマーディ欲しいということはないんで
とっくにサマーディの経験があるんだから思い出せばすぐ出てきちゃうんです
ですから 一つのこの自分がそのエネルギーを持っている
持ってるんだけど サマーディから脱出させて
普通の眼耳鼻舌身の次元に落ちて降りてきて
そこでヴィパッサナーして
それで悟りの境地に入っちゃうんです
で 悟りの境地に入る瞬間にまたサマーディが重ねちゃうんです
で 重ねて悟りの心が生まれるんです
ですから もし第一禅定の経験がある人が悟る瞬間で預流果になる瞬間で
確実に第一禅定の特色がついてくるんです
で 第二禅定ある人には第二禅定の特色がついてくるんです
ですから この出世間心は四重に分けているのはそういうわけなんですね
普通だったら出世間心八しかないんだけど
得ている禅定によって四重になっちゃうんですね
もし禅定を得ていないならば
第一禅定だと言ってます
が いろいろ私にとっては
いろいろ論理的な いろんな問題が見えますけどね
とにかく禅定のあ 悟った人々が第一預流果
一来果 不還果ところまで悟った人々に禅定もあったならば
生まれるまた梵天次元が別につくっているんです
場所を作るのは大変ですけど
それは浄土と言うんですね
どちらなに？浄土ではなくて
浄劫 浄劫 別な天国かどうかちょっと問題ですけど
まあ浄劫 浄劫天っていうのはこのアビハ
アタッパ スダッサ スダッシ
アカニッタという五つあります
アビハ アタッパ スダッサ
スダッシ アカニッタ それアビハはこちらはこの不捨天と書いてますけど
捨はずっとウペッカーの訳に使っていて
そちらは不捨といえばウペッカーがないという
そういう意味に まあなんかややこしくなるんですね
アビハっていうのは離れないということで
いわゆる解脱から離れないっていう意味だと思いますけどね
アタッパっていうのは悩むことは何もないんだと
もう輪廻の苦しみは消えたんだという意味で
スダッサっていうのは清らかな状態ということで
スダッシはまた同じ意味で
アカニッタっていうのは何天？無齢
ニッタっていうのは終わりということで
アカニッタっていうのは終わりがないという意味だと思います
カニッタといえばもう番目ということで
アカニッタといえばもう番目ではないんだと
いわゆる最高って意味なんですね
あの物質的な次元では一番最高のところはアカニッタなんです
そちらには行けない 普通の人は瞑想したっても
悟り 悟っている人しか行かないと
ですからアカニッタ梵天にいるのはみんな
まあ最低預流果ところ
預流果というところまででも悟っている人々なんです
で 本気になって真面目になって
例えば山の中とか森の真ん中とか
人がまるっきり入れないところとか
そういうところに隠れて
ものすごい徹底的にヴィパッサナー瞑想取ってやろうかなと思ったら
そういう天国神々が助けてくれるんです
で 禅定状態が出てきて
心の次元が変えたら教えてくれるんです
問題点なく じゃあこうしなさいと
で 禅定状態ないとコンタクト取らないんです
また本気でないとまたダメなんです
心を読めるんだから 人は本当に本気で悟りたいないかっていうことは
もうこの本人もわからないんですね
ですから あの なんかこの質問に答えとして
この立場台に一応今度は入れますけど
この本気で悟りたいっていう気持ちは出てくるのはかなり後
ヴィパッサナー進んだ後なんです
いわゆる全ては無常であることはわかって
もうナーマ・ルーパを徹底的に知って
それ流れはずっと体験して
もうものすごい徹底的に嫌な状態になるんです
全て嫌になっちゃうんです
自分のことも嫌になる
坐禅も嫌になる ヴィパッサナーも嫌になる
何しろそのいいということはなくなっちゃうんです
瞑想することも嫌になるし
瞑想をやめることも嫌になるんです
じゃあ瞑想やめてうちに帰ろう
それも嫌なうちは嫌ですよ
じゃあこっちいればこっちにいるのも嫌ですよ
瞑想してください じゃあ瞑想するのは全く嫌です
何の意味もない そういう風にもどうしようもない
すっごい強烈なこの感情みたいなものが出てくる
それで その人にはもう選ぶ道一しかないんです
それぐらいもう精神的にも無常を体験しているんです
全て無意味に感じるんです
それで捨てるという概念が初めて出てくるんです
全部やめる で それで瞑想する
瞑想やめちゃったら全部終わりますけどね
そこでまたちょっと瞑想すれば
さっとすぐその状態 状況を得たら
すぐ悟りの気持ちが生まれるんです
そこまでは人の気持ちはちょっと信頼できないんです
まあそういうことで  なんで仏教ではよく神々のいろいろ話とか出るかというと
やっぱりこの瞑想してる人々とね
話し合ったりとかね 叱られたりとかね
あるんですからね お坊さんたちでも
もう本当に立派な才能があるお坊さんで
ちょっと怠けた怠けようと思ったら
もうすぐなんとか叱られたりはするし
で そういう風にいろいろ助けはあるんです
ですから まあなかなかもう神々の話は
いくら合理的な仏教と言っても
それお釈迦様の教えは合理的ですけど
一般的な仏教になると
そういう話はまあ入ってくるんです
ですから たとえあるお坊さんが真面目に修行していて
体の調子が悪くなった
それでも自分がもうそれを無視してでも修行はしますよという気持ちが頑張ると
その人は全然知らないんだけど
自分の体に必要なものやら薬やら食べ物やら誰かカンザス持ってくる
あるいはそういう人がそこら辺に
まあ他のどこか行こうとしてたところで
なんか道に迷ったり 何とかしてでもそのお坊さんに会うと
そういうケースっていうのは
もうごく普通に この仏教の歴史の中でものすごいたくさんあるんです
そこを説明できません
だから何でしょうかと
で まあそういう誰かに助けてくれたとね
神々に助けてくれたということになっちゃうんです
自分の精神的なレベルが高くなればなるほど
高いレベルの人々が助けてくれる
一人で瞑想すると 自分の指導者にもぴったしと教えてくれることできなきゃなれば
ちゃんと自分の耳に心にその次にやるべきことはサッと入っちゃうんです
次にそういう こういうことが
こうしなさい それは直接入るんです
誰か梵天が降りてきて
君 これからこうしなさいとか言わない
お坊さんたちに君と呼べるのは梵天だけなんです
神々は怖いんです だから梵天の人々がお坊さんたちを呼ぶと
一応一般的な名前で年下の人を呼ぶような言葉で呼ぶんです
比丘だったら比丘とか比丘様とかね
要は日本語で言えば君とかね
君しっかりしなさいよと
向こうは出家ではないんだけど
梵天なんですけど やっぱり梵天っていうのは修行者の世界だから
まあそういう風に言われるみたい
ですから 仏教を信じていない神が梵天の神々でも結構きついです
神々にはもう別に問題ないんだけどね
神々はお坊さんたちよりはレベルが低いんですって
梵天の方がレベルが高い
そういう風に まあ一般的な世界の仏教の世界のいろんな考え方ありますから
面白いだから言ったんですけどね
もっとレベル低いことはこっちいっぱい書いてますからね
［笑い］じゃあ大変です
あ ああ 時間 アルーパワーチラまで行けなかった
アルーパワーチラ・ボーミは説明するとこあまりないんですけど
それはどうしても説明できないし